Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
in this video I'm breaking down the ending
of Cobra Kai Season 3, what it means for Season
4,
and revealing all the clever details and secret
easter eggs to previous seasons and all the
Karate Kid movies.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
After several seasons of "will they, won't
they?", Daniel and Johnny have finally joined
karate forces to solve their shared problem:
how to give Kreese and his Cobra Kai the chop
for good.
Teaching Kreese a lesson wasn't really something
Daniel thought he was up to before, as he
told us back in the 80s:
"That guy just doesn't know what karate's
all about."
"Yeah, well, maybe he should learn."
"Would you like to teach him?"
"No."
I wouldn't be surprised if we see that moment
mentioned in some way in Season 4;
after all, the showrunners are self-professed
super-fans that go deep with their references
from visual nods like Fernandez Meats stickers
to episode titles like Ace Degenerate.
"You're still the Ace degenerate."
"No, ex-degenerate, man."
Indeed, Johnny's come quite a way even just
this season.
I mean, look how in episode one he's punching
car windows à la John Kreese;
but, by the end, he couldn't be further removed
from his old sensei as he's teamed up with
his old rival.
As Mr Miyagi put it in one of his letters
that Kumiko reads to Danny,
"In life, we'll always lose our way.
But it is people, not the signs, that guide
us back to the right path."
Now, the season finale saw friends who'd become
enemies reunited as friends once more.
And while Daniel and Johnny might not be best
buds exactly,
"Have the man-boys filled you in on the whole
'mortal enemy karate dojo battle for the soul
of the Valley' thing?"
they are allies now at least, so they're on
the right path.
After all, as Ali told them:
"And the truth is..
you guys are more alike than you want to admit."
Or as Kreese would say:
"The enemy of your enemy...
is your friend."
Interestingly, when Kreese said those words
to Hawk earlier this season, he was talking
about Robby, who'd put their fellow Cobra
Miguel in a coma but had now turned against
Daniel and Miyagi-Do.
So, it's clear that Kreese is just using Robby
to get what he wants: revenge.
"You know, when I was overseas, it was hard
to tell who was the enemy."
In fact, Kreese has got Robby so brainwashed,
thinking that mercy is a weakness for losers,
that he can't see Kreese is the real enemy,
not his dad or Daniel.
"I won't fight you."
"You are weak."
Indeed, Robby thinks Kreese is the good guy:
"He only wants what's best for you."
Given everything Johnny knows about his old
sensei, seeing his kid side with him and the
way Kreese calls Robby 'son' must really hurt.
After all, we saw how Johnny reacted when
he discovered Daniel was training Robby in
Season 1.
Still, as Daniel told Johnny this season:
"The whole reason these kids got into trouble
was because of us;
we can't let them suffer because of our issues;
the only way to end this is by working together."
In other words, just as Kreese told Daniel
in episode 1 about their eventual face-off,
this was all inevitable.
And that's because this whole situation is
as much about the past as it is the present.
And the title of the finale, December 19,
confirms that.
The showrunners have said they really care
about their titles, and often tie them thematically
to the episode's content and to the original
movies.
And the date in this title does both, as it's
the day Daniel beat Johnny in the 1984 All
Valley Tournament.
Kreese still hasn't got over what happened
that day as his whole philosophy of life and
karate lost to Mr Miyagi's diametrically opposed
ethos.
Although his own actions afterwards caused
him to lose all his students and go broke,
he placed the blame elsewhere.
And while his and his old army buddy's schemes
for payback at the next tournament failed
in the Karate Kid 3, he's obviously hoping
it's third time lucky:
"Why don't we settle this the old-fashioned
way?
Tournament.
If we lose...
I go.
If you lose..."
"We won't lose."
But will Kreese actually leave peacefully
if he does lose?
Quite possibly not, because as Johnny said,
"You can't trust him!"
By the way, notice how Kreese looks at Johnny
when he says "if you lose" because he's goading
him about his second place back in '84, something
Kreese took personally:
"Second place is no place!
You're off the team!
You're nothing!
You lost.
You're a loser!"
This season went into Kreese's backstory,
and we learned that as a young man he was
more like Hawk, Miguel, or Tory, dealing with
a rough life, family hardships, and bullies.
And, like them, he took to heart some flawed
lessons from an authority figure, modelling
himself after his Captain in Vietnam,
adopting not just his interest in martial
arts and his cigar habit, but most damagingly,
his 'kill or be killed', 'shed your humanity',
merciless attitude.
Kreese led his students down that same wrong
path;
and decades later, one of them did the same
with his own students, until he wised up.
But with Kreese in the Cobra Kai driving seat
again, he's perpetuating the cruel 'no mercy'
cycle, passing it on to a new generation,
This will never be over LaRusso.
You hear me?"
and treating schoolkids like they're in a
war:
Fighting his mentor in Vietnam was a seminal
moment for Kreese becoming the man we know
today.
Interestingly, it only happened because he
stepped in to save his army pal, Silver.
But when their allies arrived bringing with
them the possibility that both Kreese and
his Captain could make it out of their battle
to the death alive, Kreese made a choice about
the kind of man he wanted to be.
In a way, in the finale, Johnny is also only
there fighting his mentor because of someone
else;
his protégé, Miguel, who's been badly beaten
by the Cobra Kai kids.
And just as Kreese took over from his Captain
after their fight, season 4 will likely bring
a similar opportunity for Johnny.
But back in the here and now, Johnny refuses
to fight his son as, unlike Kreese, he's no
longer willing to continue his mentor's merciless
cycle with the younger generation, because
as he told his students:
"I wasn't taught the difference between mercy
and honor and I paid the price for it."
In fact, he even vetoed them fighting dirty.
"The baddest badass is the one who beats his
opponent when he's at his strongest.
Not when his back is turned."
But just as Kreese's Captain tried to exploit
his humanity by revealing his girlfriend's
death right before their fight, Kreese himself
is happy to take advantage of Johnny's humanity
as he tends to his unconscious son.
And look what's in shot right after that:
an All Valley tournament poster, reminding
us what this is all about and how it will
end.
Kreese reverts to his old Karate Kid Part
II ways when he starts to choke Johnny.
It's not the first time we've seen Kreese
get him in a chokehold in this series, though
last time he was demonstrating the move in
class, rather than actually trying to take
him out.
But as Kreese said at the top of the season,
he thought he and Johnny would be fighting
Daniel together, which is what I think it
means when he tells Johnny:
"This isn't how I wanted this to end."
And the way he kicks his former student away
here after choking him reminds me of how Johnny
pushed Kreese away after using the chokehold
on him when he first arrived back in season
2.
As for how Kreese deals with Daniel when he
turns up, let's just say there's definitely
a recurring theme of smashing his opponents
into glass in the show.
Which is likely a call-back to when he and
his buddy Silver fought Mr Miyagi in the third
Karate Kid movie.
Of course, in the second movie, Kreese also
kept smashing his fists into car windows as
he failed repeatedly to punch Danny's sensei.
And while Kreese can't stop resorting to dirty
tactics,
"Time for you and Miyagi to reunite!"
he's once again outmanoeuvred by Miyagi-do
techniques, this time the secret "pressure
points" that Chozen taught Danny.
"If an enemy insists on war...
then you take away their ability to wage it."
Given he was interrupted by his daughter,
I wonder if next season they'll address how
Danny would have ended the fight.
It certainly didn't feel like he was going
out in Mr Miyagi style.
A couple of other interesting details here
are the colours Daniel and Johnny are wearing,
reminiscent of their showdown at the end of
the film.
Also, this image of Sam with her father and
Miguel beside Johnny just as Robby arrives
would doubtless reinforce in Robby's mind
his earlier accusation that his dad treats
Miguel more like a son than him.
And just as the season 2 finale used a phone
to foreshadow the return of another original
movie character for the next season,
this time a phone call by Kreese lets us know
that the third film's main villain, his army
pal Terry Silver, will be turning up in Season
4.
In the show, a young Silver goes by the nickname
Twig and only makes it out of Vietnam alive
thanks to his friend.
"I owe you, man.
You saved my ass.
Anything you need...
I'm there for you.
You hear me, Johnny?
Your whole life!
I owe you."
Given the phone call then, it looks like we'll
see actor Thomas Ian Griffith, who played
Silver in the movie, back in action;
especially as he said only last year that
"it would be fun to see the whole gang" again.
Silver's been happily repaying Kreese's life-saving
over the years, from founding Cobra Kai for
him to wreaking revenge on Daniel and Miyagi
when Kreese went out of business.
And with just how much Silver revelled in
sneaking around and inflicting pain and humiliation
back in the 80s,
I'm sure he'll love teaming up with Kreese
again to give Daniel, Johnny, and their students
a taste of the nasty medicine he thinks they
deserve for everything they've done to his
old army friend.
I wonder what devious schemes he'll dream
up this time!
Now, when it came to fighting Silver and Kreese
in the movie, Mr Miyagi easily defeated them,
but how will Daniel and Johnny do in the show?
Of course, Ralph Macchio and William Zabka
are the stars of the series, so they'll certainly
triumph in the end, but the writers have got
ten episodes, that's over five hours, compared
to a two-hour movie.
So, I imagine we'll get some stand-offs between
the adult leads before their final big showdown,
and a lot of training and confrontations for
the younger characters before the tournament!
And if you haven't had enough Cobra Kai yet,
you can discover more of the amazing details
cleverly hidden in the show in my Things You
Missed video.
Tap here to watch that or follow the link
in the video description.
So, what did you think of the latest season?
And what would you like to see happen in season
4?
Leave your comments below!
And if you enjoyed this, don't forget to leave
a thumbs-up, it's hugely appreciated.
Now tap left for my next video or tap right
for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!